it looks like someone was angry with a
European Central Bank
maybe savers upset with low interest
rates low interest rates and high
banking charges are shrinking savings
even pensioners like Hans Kaiser are up
in arms but there's always the promise
of profits at the stock exchange you
don't get anything anymore sure a lot of
older people would prefer to buy fixed
interest rate bonds but there's a fear
of negative interest rates we'd be
losing money year by year it's time to
start gambling
it's time to take some risks the
Frankfurt Stock Exchange risk is bread
and butter for traders here they earn
when stocks rise and when they fall at
the moment market prices are going up
the dax is at record levels but you need
to keep the risk under control not
everybody copes well with risk taking
risks isn't a very german thing to do
but i define risk differently today it's
a risk not having stocks if my money is
in state bonds i'm throwing it away
instead of saving for old age a little
bit here a lot more their risk needs to
be spread that can work but also fail
we're visiting fund managers their jobs
have been getting tedious they have to
look a lot longer to find lucrative
deals 7% on government bonds is possible
if you can live with the risk of a Total
Wipeout
investors in Greece lost half their
money in the bailout haircut we can't
promise anything and we don't promise
anything it's always a question of
relative risk if a customer is prepared
to take a lot of risk then we can
develop strategies or portfolios which
produce higher returns certainly
some savers have taken out all their
capital and invested it in real estate
that's making itself noticed with low
interest rates and cheap money demand is
growing this is a new development in
Frankfurt a four room luxury flat can
cost as much as seven hundred thousand
euros but will rent income grow every
rise in the rent improves the
relationship to the cost add time to the
equation and there's your profit but
it's a bet on rising rentals the
predictions say that rents will go up
all the signs say they will there's no
sign that interest rates are going to go
up but no one knows for certain
you